[Müzik]
hoş geldiniz
Ben bugün size 4000 yıllık bir araftan
bahsedeceğim
konuşmakla susmak arasında kalmışlığın
hissini
kekemeliği anlatacağım
bundan 4000 yıl önce bulunan bir kil
tablette şu cümleleri rastlanmış
Tanrım kekemeliğimin bel kemiğini kır
Dilerim ki engelimin kaynağını kurutasın
ve 4000 yıl yani yetip gitmiş Bir ruhum
bu sitemi her yıl Milyonlarca kişi
tarafından tekrar ediliyor 4.000 yıldır
Peki neden çünkü bilmiyoruz Yanlış ya da
eksik biliyoruz
Benim adım Seda çocukluğumun deyimiyle
SSS Seda bunu defalarca çoğaltabilirim
aileden Daha doğrusu anne tarafından
bana miras olarak geçen bu özelliği
Kendimi Bildim Bileli taşıyorum İlk
zamanlar bir ismi yoktu Bir hissi de
yoktu yani hissi de normalde evde Bana
bazen işte Seda diyen bazen SS Seda diye
seslenen Bir ailem vardı ve bana nasıl
seslenildiğinde benim için bir önemi
yoktu ta ki ilkokulun ilk gününe kadar
ben orada öğrendim İlerleyen zamanlarda
bana şekilcilik üzerinden bir değer
biçileceğini hepimiz yaşamışızdır sınıfa
bir öğretmen
gelir herkesten adını söylemesini ve
kendini tanıtmasını ister bizde de öyle
oldu Bir öğretmen geldi İşte herkes
sırasıyla adını söylüyor Biz de böyle
arkadan bir coşkuyla koro halinde tekrar
ediyorduk
Sonra sıra bana geldi ayağa kalktım
bir SS Seda dedim
ve öğretmen sordu Evet arkadaşlar
arkadaşınızın Adı neymiş dedi tüm sınıf
bir coşkuyla Koru halinde SS Seda diye
tekrar etti önce minik bir sessizlik
oldu Sonra bir kahkaha koptu ben önce
velilerin güldüğünü hatırlıyorum önce
veliler güldü sonra öğrenciler güldü Ben
de kaçıp kendi veliyimin arkasına
Saklandım ve Ne yaşandığını Anlamadım
çünkü adımı yanlış söylemiş
olamazdım
sonra öğretmen geldi
ve kızınız kekeliyor mu kekememi diye
sordu yani insanın konuşma biçimi
hastalık olabilir mi Ben bunu ilk
duyunca hastalık zannettiğimi
eve gidip bana ilaç verin beni
iyileştirin dediğimi tepinerek
ağladığımı ve annemin o anını kurtarmak
için bana bir şurup verdiğini
hatırlıyorum Tabii bunun da bitmedi yani
bu sadece alışmak zorunda olacağım bir
hayatın ön fragmanı gibi bir şeydi
Önce
kekemeliktedir
teyze bundan bahsedeyim
Bugün Türkiye'de 1 milyon bireyi
etkileyen kekemelik en basit tanımı ile
konuşmanın akışını bozan tekrarlar
bloklar uzatmalar duraklamalar ve
eklemelerle karakterize bir konuşma
bozukluğu olarak tanımlanıyor ve bu
bozukluğun nedeni henüz bilinemiyor
nöroloji dil bilgisi çevresel ve
psikolojik faktörler önemsenip Bunlar
üzerinden
açıklanmaya çalışılıyor dil ve konuşma
terapistlerince uygulanan çeşitli
terapilerle kontrol altına alınabiliyor
azaltabiliyor fakat tamamen ortadan
kalkmıyor Bizim de arafımız
burada başlıyor ben
dışarıdan tamamen çözümsüz olarak
algılanan bir iletişim becerisine sahibi
ve toplum ne yazık ki buna hazır değil
bu nasıl oluyor benim Beynimin konuşma
merkezi
sizlerden biraz farklı olarak kafasına
göre takılıyor yani konuşmamın ne zaman
ve nasıl yapacağımı keyfine göre karar
veriyor yani Konuşma merkezine bir el
konuşmama da bir fiş olarak düşünürsek
eğer o fişi her an belki de şu an
çekebilir Peki ne olur yani ofis çekilse
beynim kafasına göre takılsa en fazla ne
olabilir mesela
Adını bile söyleyemiyorsun İşte bu ne
biçim konuşma Senin Türkçe öğretmenin
Kim Sen Önce konuşmayı öğren Hiç mi
okula gitmedin gibi sorularla
karşılaşırsınız günlük hayatta sıklıkla
bazı alışkanlıklar ve Korkular
edinmesini Mesela biz bunları
kaçınma davranışı deriz Örneğin en büyük
korkularımdan birisi Bir gün Burak
adında bir patronla çalışmak Burak Bey
böyle hayatımın korkulu kelimelerinden
Sadece biri
Burak çıksa ki çıkmaz Çünkü bdrk gibi
harflerle aram hiç iyi değil cümle
içerisinde Burak çıksa Bey çıkmayacak Bu
durumda Koskoca patrona'ya sadece Burak
demiş olacağım ya da ismi hiç yokmuş
gibi davranacağım aynı şekilde Hanım
ifadesi beni çok zorlar Çünkü h harfi
bende çoğu zaman k sesi ile çıkar o
yüzden birisi bana adımla hitap
edebilirsiniz dediğinde aşırı mutlu
olurum ama adının ne olduğu da önemli
mesela ismi Tek mi çift mi Çift ismi
varsa ve ikisini de kullanıyorsa ne olur
bana göre kolay olanı kullansın gibi
temennilerim olur Bazen sonra devrik
cümleler
kurabilirsiniz konuşabilmek derdinizi
anlatabilmek adına asılak seslere
kelimelerin eş anlamlılarına sıklıkla
başvurabilirsiniz
dizilere filmleri günlük hayatta
rastlayamayacağınız kekemelik şiddetinde
mizahu olarak konu olabilir
sonra olması gereken yerde olması
gereken tepkiyi veremediğiniz için
kimine göre
utangaç kimine göre flörtöz kimine göre
agresif kimine göre ezik olursunuz çünkü
akıcılıktan başka
iletişim biçimi yoktur varsa kişi
anormaldir toplumumuzdaki Algın ne yazık
ki böyle sonra adres sorarken ya da
tarif ederken
yargılanmamak için kağıda yazıp vermeyi
Tercih edebilirsiniz bazen insanlar Siz
o kadar dinlemez ki sırf ilgilerini
çekip sizi dinlesinler de derdiniz ne
anlatabileyim diye yabancı değil öğrenip
turist taklidi yapmak zorunda bile
kalabilirsiniz günlük hayatta
utanmıyor musun bazen
utanmamakla
suçlanabilirsiniz toplum içerisinde
kurumsal hayatta okulda vesaire alışmış
olduğumuz ve esnetemediğimiz bazı
kurallarımız var Bunlardan birisi sunum
kuralları ki bizler için gerçekten çok
zor size bu burada bir arkadaşımın
başından geçen bir olay aktaracağım
kekemeliği olan bu arkadaşım
üniversitede sunum yapıyor ve kendi yani
konuşmasını yapısı gereği de kekeleyerek
konuşuyorsun esnasında sunum bitiyor ve
Hocası arkadaşım odasına çağırıp şu
cümleyi kuruyor utanmıyor musun bu yaşta
üniversitede böyle konuşmaya şimdi
Muhtemelen hocamız kekemeliğin ne
olduğunu bilmiyor ama bilmiyorsa daha
fena bence çünkü işte utanmak
heyecanlanmak panik olmak böyle insana
ait Yani
varoluşumuzda yer alan hisler değil mi
zaten ben
robot değil insansan en nihayetinde
neden bunları sergilediğim için
utanayım hani çok başarılı profesyonel
bir konuşmacı dahi olsa bu hisleriniz
sergilemeye hiç hakkı yok mu gerçekten
Sonra işte göz teması kur sakın
seyirciler kanı dönme tüm Salonu kontrol
altında sana soru sormalarını sağla öyle
zor ki tüm Bunların hepsi Benim ve bizim
için yani gerçekten çok zor Şu an Mesela
ben bunları yapamıyorsam Siz beni
dinlemez misiniz Bence dinlersiniz Yani
neden nasıl anlattığımız Neyi
anlattığımızdan daha değerli
bizim için kritik olan soru bu fark
ettiyseniz
sürekli dinlemek diyorum Çünkü
kekelediği için gerçekten dinlenilmenin
ne olduğunu bilmeyen hep insanların
böyle vakitlerini çalıyormuş işte
dinleme süreleri ile yarışıyormuş gibi
hissedilen yani birisi olarak burada
konuşuyorum Benim yolculuğumda böyle
başladı dinlenilmeyerek Ben ilkokulun
ilk günü kekelediğimi öğrendim aklım
yetti ve artık yani kalbim kırılmaya
başladı Bir gün okul arkadaşım bana
kızıp evde benim taklidimi yapınca
annesi çıktı ve kapıya geldi
Seda'dan çocuğuma kekemelik bulaşacak
Bir daha arkadaşlık etmelerini
istemiyorum dedi Ve o öyle olmaz diyen
annemi de beni de dinlemedi ve biz bir
daha arkadaştık etmedik sonra eve gelen
İşte insanların sayısı arttı ve ben
aralarında katılamayınca sözel olarak
artık onları izlemeye başladım ve şunu
fark ettim eve gelen giden kimsede
Aslında birbirini dinlemiyor Yani
birbirinin gözlerine bakan böyle
hisseden kimse yok Aslında var birini
bir şeyi çok iyi dinliyorlar o kadar iyi
o kadar odaklı dinliyorlar ki tüm
sohbetleri iletişimleri dahi neredeyse
oraya kurulu
nedir bu televizyon evin içinde tüm gün
ajanslar açık oluyordu ve ben bir şey
anlatmaya çalışırken işte mesela su
isterken işte Hoş geldiniz derken Daha
doğrusu demeye çalışırken bu çabamı
görüp Ay Ne Tatlı deyip böyle sözümü
kesip işte yanağından makas alan Bu
kişiler televizyona dikkat kesiliyordu
Ben konuşurken göz devirenler ajansları
sunan abileri ablaları full dikkat
dinliyordu böyle birbirlerinden bile
daha çok daha dikkatli
bende bir gün oturdum tüm dikkat o
abileri ablaları izlemeye başladım
farklı olan ne bunu anlamaya
çalışıyordum şunu gördüm
bu abiler ablalar Çevremdeki kimse gibi
konuşmuyorlardı ben gibi değil annem
gibi değil ama babam gibi değil Ben
kayseri'liyim böyle hani bir Kayseri
ağzı vardı evde televizyonda o da yok
Herkes onları dinliyorsa benim için
kendimi dinletmenin tek bir yolu vardı
onlar gibi
olmak en nasıl olacak cevabı beni bir
gün ajansları izlerken yakalayan annem
verdi Ee onlar gibi olmak istiyorsan
dedi
iletişim okumalısın e dedim tamam
herhalde okursam kekemeliyim geçer ve
artık herkes beni dinler Ben böyle
olmayacağını lisede öğrensem de
vazgeçmedim önce 2 yıllık okudum sonra
mezun olup çalışırken
topluluk önünde konuşamadığım yani sunum
yapamadığım için iş arkadaşlarım iş
fikirlerimi çalınca
işten ayrılıp böyle Fakültesi İletişim
Fakültesi
dağın tepesinde kurulu olan bir
üniversiteyi geçiş yaptım
Eğer servisi kaçırırsanız bu fakülteye
300 küsür olduğu düşünülen merdivenleri
kullanarak çıkıyorsunuz şimdi her
Bireyde farklı olmak üzere benim
kekemeliğim ilk şey ne tetikler
birincisi uykusuzluk ikincisi fiziksel
yorgunluk o günde hem uykusuzluk hem de
merdivenleri koşarak çıkmanın etkisiyle
yani kekemelik ortaya çıktı Çünkü beynim
artık orada fişi çekti Öyle yorgun ve o
kadar konuşamıyorum ki ağzından harfler
çıkmıyordu o sırada arkadaşımın olan
sohbeti duyan ve tanımadığım bir öğrenci
şunu dedi ne için ben seni burada hani
Bu konuşmayla senin bu fakültede ne işin
var şimdi ben sırf toplumun alışkın
olmadığı bir biçimde kendi bildiğim gibi
konuşuyorum diye çok azarlandım işte
dışlandım böyle Kapıdan Kovuldum
yüzlerce telefon suratıma kapatıldı ama
Yani ilk kez benden hesap soruldu Ben
neredeyse suçlu çıkacaktım sonra durdum
düşündüm yani bu böyle gitmez bunun daha
hızlı daha kolay bir yolu olmalı dedim
gün sonunda elimde ikisi çıktı vardı
birisi alanım iletişim diğeri de
farklılığım ikisini kullanarak güncel
hızlı ne yapabilirim diye düşündüğümde
YouTube dedik ve YouTube'da Kekilli TV
adında sadece kekemeli olan bireylere
ait bir kanal kurduk şimdi Tekeli TV
buraya kadar anlattıklarımı ve daha
fazlasını birebir yaşayan kişilerin
ağzından duyabileceğiniz bir
dayanışma ağı Biz söyleşiler röportajlar
eğitimler kampanyalar aracılığıyla
görünür kılmayı hedefliyoruz ha gerek
var mıydı bunca çabaya derseniz vardı
Çünkü ben çocukken mesleki Hayaller
kuramazdım iznim yoktu işte bir çocuğun
kurduğu öğretmen doktor polis olmak
hayalleri için benim iznim yoktu çünkü
kekemelik vardı ve bunların hiçbirini
yapamazdım Aslında ben ne istediğimi
biliyordum ama çevrem sormuyordu Çünkü
onların ve sıkı sıkıya tutunduğu
önyargıları ve olmazları vardı ki hala
var tek şeyleri yoktu çözüm ki hala yok
Benim de böyle yapabilecekleri Yani
yapamayacaklarımı değil yapacaklarımı
duymaya Belki biraz tecrübe etmeye
ihtiyacım vardı Biz de öyle yaptık işte
şimdi 1 milyondan fazla kekemeliği olan
insanın sesi olmak için ben Birçok yerde
anlatıyorum Biz hep birlikte içerikler
üretiyoruz işte sonrasında yaptığımız
çalışmaların böyle takdir görmesi her
şeyin bizim için ve toplum için daha da
Normal hale gelmesi açısından çok
değerliydi Bu yüzden yaptığımız
çalışmaları ödüllendiren bazı
kurumlarda oldu
ben yani sonuç olarak şunu söylemek
istiyorum doğrudan kekemeliğe bir etkisi
olmasa da yani Güzel konuşmanın bir
eğitimi var Evet ama keşke dinlemenin de
olsa Bizler çoğu zaman böyle
dinlemektense konuşuyor olmayı tercih
ediyoruz çünkü konuşmak dinlemekten hep
daha kolay ama Ben ve arkadaşlarım hep
en zor taraftayız O yüzden şimdi burada
Bugün size şunu istiyorum şimdi bugün
bir düşünün kaç kişiyi dinlediniz kaç
dakika dinlediniz Gerçekten mi
dinlediniz Yoksa sizi sıra gelsin mi
istediniz Bugün bir durun bir düşünün
bir dinleyin Bir de kendinizi dinletmeyi
deneyin Bakalım ne kadar zor olabilir
beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]